should we jump over now to reggaeton the
UN yes we should
oh gosh this i retweeted this cuz it's
so silly it's amazing where it sits it's
a culture war ii social justice kind
even in everybody how are you all doing
yeah UN takes heat for bizarre
gender-neutral language language code oh
man sometimes I think like we're out of
we're out of the you know we've made it
through the forest through the desert
the culture war the social justice weird
insane stuff nope it's just a ravine and
you fall back alright now into a pit
it's like no you're climbing the last
dune and they're like it's just over
there it's like we've made it you climb
to the top and then it's just like the
Sahara rise fall to your knees it's
still happening it's worse this is the
UN so the UN tweeted out one of the
stupidest things I have ever seen the
United Nations is taking heat after
posting a bizarre new dictionary of
gender neutral terms to replace more
gendered words used in everyday life
with social media users expressing the
wildermann and confusion at the language
policing that in some cases appeared to
backfire quote help here's what you say
matters help create a more equal world
by using gender-neutral language if
you're unsure about someone's gender or
are referring to a group on women org I
love that I like that
okay don't say mankind say humankind so
that's ridiculous
it's the same thing know what they're
all equally stupid they're all is this
awesome I want you all to know that when
our government gives money to the UN
this is what they are fund
don't say chairman say chair or chair
that doesn't make any sense either the
chair the chair the chair I'm I'm
talking to the chair right now like well
you're crazy yeah that see that at least
would make some semblance of sense look
at this don't say congressman say
legislature but that's not a logic clear
that's not clear and why can't you say
congresswoman right is what they do yeah
you have s woman and Congressman yeah oh
it's because it's gender-neutral because
it might be a floor bow oh I see and you
don't know so it would be Congress floor
but uh wait wait it gets it gets really
really it gets so much better
don't say businessman say representative
but representative refers to Congress
beautiful designers persons that doesn't
make sense either
none of this dude dude dude wait don't
say police man say police officer okay
so that's the first one that that's sure
but you usually say police officer
anyway but here's what I don't
understand or cop yeah is it doesn't
officer refer to ranking members
hierarchy yeah is it isn't it like once
you become a lieutenant you're an
officer I guess they call all police
officers it's weird I guess it means
that's official duty yet so like yeah I
dig that but like it's weird this next
one's ridiculous this is the best one
don't say landlord say owner okay that's
it I'm done the UN just told me to refer
the my landlord as my owner
what could you imagine what life would
be like in the Bronx or Harlem Oh South
Side of Chicago technically you're my
landlord right now so I want you to do
listen listen everybody everybody
everybody here's what I want you to do
go to New York go to Chicago go to the
south side go to Harlem and talk to
someone about rent and ask the
individuals who live there do you feel
like your owner is treating you well and
see how they respond to that wow I
didn't even think about yeah it's bird
you you as a well-to-do white person who
was advised by the UN to refer to the
landlords as owners go to the minority
communities and say is your owner taking
care of all of you they're gonna be like
what do you mean my owner yeah say
they're gonna get punched in the face it
let's say that one more time
Oh what did you say depending what
neighborhood you're gonna get that
that's the most I'm saying this is this
is like this is really bad advice like
is dangerous could you imagine being in
Chicago and walk up someone and be like
I love to talk to you about your owner
whoa what dude what
amazing knoweth bed boy I love this one
boyfriend a girlfriend say partner
now this one is triggering you know why
why because I once had a business
partner in this project okay business
partner I'm like what am I supposed to
call him and so I was like you know
talking to people and I kept saying you
know my partner is set up you know the
company and in this and then someone was
like it's it's so great that a gay
couple can be out and open and I was
like what my business partner like it's
a it's a human and we're doing a company
together and they were like oh I'm not
gonna say the word partner anymore I'm
out cuz it no longer refers to you yeah
it the connotation was changing and now
they're trying to do this
yeah they changed it the rest of them
are it's it's so hilarious man look at
this
don't say salesman say salesperson well
why not just say Congress person or
business person or police person right
what why what you know while they're
running out running out of alternative
things to say somebody somebody at the
UN was like a higher up came down and
said can you do something unlike gender
language like yeah well write something
up and they had no idea how any of it
works and they were like can you just
give me some words why can't you say
land Lord how is land Lord gendered you
say landlady I've said that what's wrong
with that landlady yeah wait yeah what's
what's up with the Lord like is Lord's I
got like a woman can't be a Lord the
landlady dude a landlord can be female
we just did a story I agree I just did a
segment about is an taifa guy uh-huh and
it turned out his landlords grandma
uh-huh like all right you say landlord
yeah exactly
is Lord male my no words and ladies is
it but it's like couldn't there be but I
go to Skyrim for example one of the
yards is a woman and it's cuz her
husband died and she became the Earl and
it's like that's kind of the same thing
as what I think is like a Lord it would
be you know if like the the male died
and the woman became the Lord then they
pulled they pulled words that hats yes
it is
they're like written the wait chair no
no they have one of those cylindrical
like bingo things and they're spinning
it I got you I got
there's two of them there's two of them
this time - and they pull a pulls one
out knee goes
we have chairman and then they pulls out
chair they mean two different things
yeah roll with it let's go with it here
gets better
don't say men power say workforce but
what's funny is manpower and workforce
mean different things manpower is a
reference to the the energy like expense
you have from enough individuals
manpower can refer to it means humans
like if you said we don't have the
manpower to move this this Boulder
that's a number of people if it's like
could you imagine we don't have the work
force to move this Boulder like the work
force like that's a weird way of
phrasing thing one small step for what
would you say I don't don't say
horsepower say horse force horse here's
here's a next one this is just so dumb
made a name family name I mean Adam
what's your family name
Craig ler no no your family name I
thought I answered what's your mom's
family name Skoglund know your family
name family name means your last name
that's right I said first and you said
no I know that's the point if family
name refers to bump the maiden name and
your current name this makes literally
no sense yo - woman say so what's your
family name yeah no no no I mean your
family name my family name is pool I
mean like before you were married Oh
maiden name oh okay hmm yes okay how can
you how can you have a word that means
like a phrase that means something it
means two things that are contradictory
right that's a good point cuz not
everyone takes their the husband's name
like I'm obviously this is about like
being married and your maiden name is
what it was before you got married all
right
like he sure doesn't didn't take my name
I don't care like it makes no difference
to me yeah she still has her last name
that's fine so if if you do change your
name and then you're trying to say it
family name but you're already changed
your name wiggler which is another thing
people are already upset about - because
that's antiquated also is like
you're you're not owned by them you're
not leggings yeah taking names it's not
like mr. and mrs. Adam Craig ler but
that's weird that mean it sounds weird
to me no I don't think so I think that's
just your one family now
well then I think it makes a lot us that
would be your family name the new family
you just started so I would actually
rather us both change her name when
we've actually talked about it yeah it's
something cool like like like a grand
smash or doomhammer no funny enough it
probably would be my mother's maiden
name why is it for me well my
grandfather just kind of kind of raised
why do our own last names like pool
maybe we're gonna have something cool
like you know like like cool like like
like world Endor or something you know
or like like tomb world finger Death
Bringer sure well what this is my family
we're the Death Bringer surrounding yeah
we're the complicated's
oh I like that no that actually that
actually does the forums that actually
um it actually makes sense that you'd
start a new family and you'd have a new
family name but I think actually makes
sense like if you if you marry someone
have kids you're now a family unit was
the name of your family yeah it's like
your clan almost you know so this is
just more nonsense husband and wife say
spouse why no why but she is my wife
well I guess you could be in a gay
relationship or something then you use
spouse or your husband if you're in a
gay relation to do well no no but I
think they're they're saying is that if
I went to you and I don't know you and I
said is your wife coming I'd be making
an assumption about the gender right so
that would make your part in that
situation to you spouse spouse is your
spouse Colusa I suppose is your s point
isn't it that actually means wife I
suppose ah yeah yeah I do so is it yeah
male I think I don't that's the funniest
thing about all this language stuff is
that Spanish is like could you imagine
oh how they do like the exes lateen ex
thinks like Kleenex okay so just the way
they say they say it no no said like you
know sound Latino mmm-hmm the
progressives change the O's and A's to
exes okay
you can't speak Spanish that way
like me perixx SME Amiga X ones like
what you're not saying words that's a
huge part of that language isn't it a
big part of all Romance languages though
yes English is okay not not romance like
we just yes yeah they're so male and
female version of everything is we have
like no gender or something they have a
third word for the people that don't
aren't like his or her and then the
third but isn't yeah what do you miss
but what do you mean like we have they
no no no no they is plural like they
doesn't makes like you we've talked
about it it doesn't make sense all the
time it makes sense in the context of an
individual that isn't is right
specifically specifically but they have
a word
there's him/her and the third floor
essentially floor bow but it's it's been
y'all laughing at me y'all laughed at me
floor but ahead of his time now oh yeah
we have a word that specifically
references non-traditional inner
straight up I don't gotta say it I don't
guys a they just say Vlore bow floor bow
kind there you go chair floor bow boom
Congress floor bones bones police floor
bow this is fun land floor bow fire
floor bow fire floor but yeah garbage
floor bow got a good flow to it yeah I
thought floor bow was like a funny like
foofy fluffy word you know saw horrible
yeah it's like it's it's it should
invoke visions of cute puffy little
marshmallow creature when you wanna
Hearst told me that I all I could
picture was flubber you see there you
don't talk about the rubbery bouncing
Williams I was like okay little silly
little cute little guy who bounces
around it's all its happy and bouncing
flowers it's at Laurel right oh I
imagine I imagine a puffy little
marshmallow creature that wants to smile
and give you a hug okay I'm like how
could anyone get me get mad that this
was the ultimate solution in my opinion
because the idea was like if they want
you to say they or 0 sir some people get
offended by being told what to say
yeah some people get offended by not
being called the thing they want to be
called the comp
Mises to make up a new word that has no
connotations no connection to everything
and I'm like there's a lot of words that
might be too close to one thing
look florabelle yeah it's funny because
if that that was the one thing I always
said there's like the they thing they
them is confusing to a lot of people
because we're taught it's a plural part
of it I mean it is I know and it makes
sense in very specific sentences like
you explained but we needed a new word
to come up with something and floor bow
probably wouldn't be what I came up with
but I can't God didn't come up with
anything I wanted to be right that's
great
random and like nobody's used it as an
insult or anything like that you will
say it you know passively kind of
humorously it's like you know the the
the the they thing is funny because I
was I was talking recently I think with
Lydia about they/them good it's like it
makes sense when you say a lawyer walks
in the room ah they handed me a you know
a briefcase right cuz you don't know if
it's a male or a female well actually if
it was a reference to you you would say
he or she cuz you know okay what if you
said like a lawyer you know fell down
the stairs at you know this office
building they broke both our legs yeah
because you don't know right but then
what if you said like what was the
sentence with the example waves or
something like I don't remember a lawyer
a lawyer sold a customer a book they
charged in 50 bucks if you then said a
lawyer sold a book and the cashier
bagged it they charged the customer 50
bucks they is a reference to like both
of them I guess but that makes no sense
would it be the cashier who sold them
the cashier is the one who bagged it
today you don't learn anything so an
actual language we would say a lawyer
sold someone you know sold the customer
the book the cashier bagged it the
lawyer charged 50 dollars you know I
mean you go back to the proper like the
back to the description of it right
that's why I think the problem with the
vase stuff and this gender-neutral stuff
is like it's almost like a child coming
to you and being like could you imagine
a little kid seven years old whose name
is like you know Billy Watson okay
and he's like no from now on my name is
hawk battle Smasher you'd be like your
name is not Hawk battle Smasher that's
stupid no it's cool I'm hot
battle Smasher it is pretty cool other
Doomhammer yeah user warcraft names
seven year old
but it's like that's a lot of what we're
getting mmm thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune into this channel subscribe hit the
like button or check us out on iTunes
and Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you